you know what movie I'm so goddamn
excited to see it's not even funny
Napoleon yeah oh my God this movie looks
incredible I didn't even hear him yeah
we really wiped Napoleon from the
history books we talk about the French
like their [__] and they never want
to war they almost conquered the world
come on dude we've completely wiped that
away like they Retreat from every battle
they're a bunch of [__] that is our
idea that is like the British American
idea of the French propaganda Napoleon
was busting their ass now to be fair
he's Italian
he's from Corsica yeah let's just be
honest right at the time Corsica is part
of France but he's a real Italian guy
he's got that Roman blood we need to
conquer the world and there's no way a
real French person every great leader is
an outsider okay talk that [__] yeah the
great was not Greek yeah at least
Macedonian the Macedonia there is no
Greek Empire at the time the macedonians
were the Empire that's the other thing
Greece doesn't exist until you know yeah
there's no real Grace I know the Greeks
are going to be upset about this but
like Greece doesn't exist until much
later there were tiny Empires that not
even Empires they were tiny like uh
city-states what do they call them
police or something like that yeah and
uh they all looked at themselves as
their own independent countries so it
wasn't like yeah we're all Greek yeah
Greek was the common language yeah I
didn't know Athens I thought Athens and
Sparta had beef the way like they do
[__] Philly and DC happy but we're
still American they were like we had
beef and that's it like beef yeah yeah I
feel like there's a story of like every
country like India is like all these
warring tribes and then now they're
Indian now but there was a great Indian
uh Emperor who like organized that [__]
I forget that motherfucker's name I was
just reading about it no I don't know
but yeah same with like the Persians
like yo the Persians were perfect for
bad [__] life and we don't hear you
know learn about them at all because
they're Iranian but I didn't know that
about that nobody would even this is
gonna be sound crazy nobody would talk
about Alexander the Great if he didn't
take down the Persian Empire I think he
killed or I don't know if he killed
Cyrus or maybe Cyrus died in battle but
like he took out the Persians nobody
done that before yeah because crossing
the mountains was crazy but Alexander
the Great was about that business
Genghis Khan we my dad said like it was
just crazy how many people did he run
through y'all I don't know if you ran
through y'all my dad always tells me a
story about like just how brutal he was
he said his whole goal when he took over
one Village was to be so [__] awful
to them and Massacre them so thoroughly
the next Village would hear about it and
be like let's just not even let's
surrender before they even come if you
fight you're gonna get [__]
slaughtered yeah that's crazy anyway
there's Napoleon [__] like uh I sent you
that article that apparently before
Hitler you I remember you telling us
people in the early 1900s and they talk
about like the worst man ever like who's
the most evil person you could ever like
personify it was Napoleon who wrote that
article
Hitler Hitler's friend
I don't know I just they wrote it before
Hitler was born
the reason why I'm saying is that that
might be like British propaganda oh
right okay because like that's the thing
Napoleon
wild dude
I was talking to Shane about this
actually we're at the cellar and uh Tim
but like he invents the idea of the war
state
which is kind of like what we all have
now like if you look at America in World
War II Ford stops making the cars and
they start making the vehicles for war
right and the whole country operates as
a war machine the military-industrial
complex this idea is invented by
Napoleon internal industry into war the
country
is war that's Total War right Total War
the women are doing it like everyone's
involved what we think a lot of times
with Total Wars we think of Tecumseh
Sherman which you were referencing
earlier and that's more just like I'm
gonna Blaze through everything yeah [__]
yes and then and which when you think
about it's like it's a really tragic way
of looking at War because you lose not
only do you lose all the Sinners and
lies but you lose all the culture all
the relics like yeah I mean this has
probably happened tons of times in
Europe and like the city of Babylon is
[__] done probably because of
Scorchers or whatever but Total War in
terms of like everybody there is working
for the cause
and
I was asking the the guys I was like
what was his competitive advantage and
he was like artillery
like other people had developed
obviously gunpowder comes from uh China
right sure uh but it was they invented
gunpowder right but like
the Canon
is Napoleon like perfected and the use
of it I mean just like busting people's
ass war strategy and I think what
happened was since Britain Russia and
maybe even Germany had to come together
I think they were called the ontants or
something like that comes together to
stop Napoleon of course we're going to
write about him as if he was the
shortest guy ever yeah the guy was like
five eight which is like normal
that's a great height I think
[Laughter]
came back
there's got to be someone right like a
Blackberry
they reincarnated as themselves they'd
be like [__] I gotta do this again [__]
five six five six Nepal but that could
be Brian's saying it yeah yeah who wrote
that article come on so wait what were
you saying about what uh it was what I
asked you about who wrote that
I mean I thought you were just trying to
get people trying to heat off Hitler
they'd be like no the Napoleon was
waiting and I think I would imagine
that's what the British are going to be
writing about this yeah because if you
also look at the things he does he was
like yo we're getting rid of monarchies
everybody's equal now he ends up in
placing his [__] brother as a king of
Spain here ends up being the complete
hypocrite and doing all the things that
you shouldn't but he stands for the
liberation of people inequality and
getting rid of the monarchy which is
oppressing these people now is he using
that as a tool to gain favor of the
oppressed you know uh working class
maybe that's possible but at the same
time like that part is left out
of History especially when comparing
them to a guy like Hitler Hitler wasn't
hey yeah we just want to liberate
everybody yeah he was like nah I'm in
charge of the whole [__] world yeah
yeah they turn Napoli into a psychology
too yeah
Napoleon complex should mean like yo you
are that guy you're him yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you think that you run the world yeah
yeah anyway I'm stoked to see that man
and also Ridley Scott like this is the
dude the guy who's directing it yeah I
mean he did um Gladiator like alien
alien also he's like a history buff and
a little bit of a conspiracy buff like
he was all about that JFK [__] like he
was on Rogan recently wasn't he maybe I
can't remember I think he was on Rogan
when did that one come out that's uh
November Napoleon Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving was great for Thanksgiving
oh really Thanksgiving and Christmas are
like big Blockbuster days that makes
sense but what about what about the
summer when when uh remember Will Smith
feels like summer movies W can correct
me it feels like summer movies are like
popcorn flick Blockbusters like Marvel
and [__] and then Blockbusters that are
also Oscar worthy November and like
December oh because that's probably
closer to the season for like Oscars and
[__] yeah yeah yeah like Lincoln came
out